welcome everybody to another episode of
the h3 podcast today's episode is
sponsored by jigsaw out in theaters
today October 27th hellofresh quick
stitch fix men and twich prime
subscribers like you'll love you now
listen we have got a really special
guest honestly that's why I'm in this
out there I had to basically dawn my
alter ego to prepare myself to to match
this guy he's powerful he's gray and
frankly I'm intimidated so I needed a
dawn this outfit okay now before we
introduce our guest I just want to say a
couple things
Jordan Peterson is coming on next week
on Thursday November 2nd you can post
questions for him on the subreddit that
thread is now up and for future updates
on the h3 podcast follow us on Twitter
at the h3 podcast that includes time
changes and all that business
so listen introducing our next guest the
doctor the doc doctor disrespect the
two-time world champion 1993 and 1994
those were huge years in gaming
competition has has honestly been off
since that year I just threw my phone it
was making sound it displeased me you
see this he's he's the most ruthless
competitor and the online gaming
community less notably however he's also
a twitch streamer that has exploded in
popularity frankly he's captivated my
heart mine with his violent speed
athleticism and momentum when he first
wife started watching him stream he
would joke that he was 6 foot 8 with a
37 inch vertical leap but seeing him he
is actually 30 and it's [ __ ]
terrifying what else was he telling the
truth about I want this but in actuality
I do think
that he is someone who has elevated the
genre of streaming like until now I have
been experienced a twitch streamer who's
done quite what he's done on Twitch
which turned it more into a performance
part but also being a pro gamer he's
someone who I respect and appreciate and
I am also going to take him out because
I'm the 3-time and I'm the prof and I'm
here to prof eyes the end of the dock
Dan bring this coward in bring this
coward in look at this coward look at
this coward have a seat
because I'm the three times three time
at what three-time world champion lawyer
97 98 99 you don't know me I'm the to
drop of the two-time yeah I'm the
three-time dude yeah minecraft casual
gaming okay
first of all I have a castle on
minecraft if my bullies didn't come into
my server and tear it down you would
have been aw I replicated the TNG
Enterprise in Minecraft and you're gonna
[ __ ] on that that's why they call me the
three times I did bring you some
collector item t-shirts I'll take it
okay I don't like that girl take a look
at this take a look at it frankly I
can't see you I'm gonna put these down
you can't see we got here that's an
eagle flying into another dream into
another world there's a lot of levels
there's depth there okay the same one
anyway
have a seat please absolutely thanks for
joining us just a little bit of me I do
appreciate that by the way I didn't mean
to disrespect you by throwing that
welcome people you sat in this chair
last no I
that's where that's where we have I said
that for all of our guests this is a
professional set up yeah this is where
we do it I'm impressed
thank you so listen that's what I was
saying like when I what first watched
your stream you were like I've got I'm
6-8 right I'm like oh this guy's a
[ __ ] comedian right like ooh six
eight and not now that I see that you're
six eight I'm like what else wasn't he
kidding about the steroid needles that I
plan in my thighs every single day
before I go live not a joke not a joke
37 inch vertical leap not a joke 1990
Lamborghini Diablo VT parked in my
garage people say why don't you ever
take it out why'd you do a V log because
it's a collector's item
right like I'm not gonna put too many
miles on it sure so you're never gonna
see it yeah I can keep going on and on
and on but you know everything is
authentic sure well I had an idea I want
to do you are you up for cuz I wanted to
actually gauge your vertical leap we
have a camera out there really yeah I do
I need I might stretch I might need to
stretch out okay okay can we go out
there and do this yeah we could dynamic
stretching
I know yes yes welcome to the three-time
world jumping vertical champion whoa got
kicks all over the place so we are here
with the doc doctor disrespect we are
putting that 72 inch vertical leap to
the test 37 inch vertical 72 inches I
want I want you you watch one punch man
there's this one scene where he jumps to
the top of the gymnasium and his head
goes through and his body's dangling
from the bottom so that's know that's
what I'd like to see okay yeah all right
let's see yeah let's see I don't have a
receding hairline it's just I hold on a
second hold on there we go we're still
looking good right I mean I was like
yeah no I think we're good we got it we
got it we got it
can we get some round applause everybody
yeah every everything he says is real my
friends it's all real okay let's head
back to the let's let's get back to the
table this is let's go
wow that was exhilarating alright well
here haha man alright thank you so much
for that display of athleticism
absolutely felt good I'm exhilarated I
wish this was a gin and tonic
we have we couldn't have listened how do
you play with these with glasses on all
day I just closed my eyes yes it's
nonsense yeah it's just uh it's all
sensory it's all audio sensory right and
then sometimes when I do open my eyes
guess what I'm gonna top two in
situation let me go ahead and try and
win this game
right bigger but uh that is a common
question that I get all the time and I
had a fight you know this is be
straight-up honest I can't see [ __ ] okay
but but Google is working on some new
prototype scopes with built-in LCD LED
1080p d3 Sony technology don't go into
it right upgraded edition what you're
looking at is a little screen yeah it
just it projects what's outside exactly
it seems a little counterintuitive but
hey it's Google yeah and between you and
I aim assist you're under like Robocop
speed hacks and stuff like that yes cool
listen do you hate this question do you
guys do you have tall guy problems
what have tall guy problems cuz you're
probably one of the tallest people I've
ever met
yeah what and like yeah tall guy
problems is a real thing right it is it
is I mean I sat in Ferraris can't fit in
them I've sat in Bugattis cannot fit in
them okay I mean this is you know
problems right mhm and for whatever
reason the Lamborghini Diablo VT was the
one and ever since then you know the
it's just little low-hanging fruit shoe
sizes shirt sizes etc but when you were
at let ik mock turtle necks like me yeah
you know spandex material stretchy not a
problem right right right
okay fair enough yeah I don't have any
of those problems but that's good to
know that you did you've sorted them I
love the headband thank you so much
the gloves I do not like yeah just kind
of improvise okay it says crunch time
though it's kind of inspiring right have
you ever thrown a football yeah a couple
of times my old man okay you play
football you're an athlete right I'm an
athlete what do you I mean I'm an out
some and literally God's gift to gaming
and right one of those features is
athleticism okay
75 yards easy throw barrel 75 yards
that's like the whole thing that's
almost the whole field right yeah like
there's people that need to kickoff you
know like I just throw the football
right yeah wow that's really cool that
you're not that you just decided to play
games and not play that professionally
yeah the money's where the games are at
right the money's on twitch money's on
twitch yeah not manifold not in a felony
yeah those guys are sorely underpaid
big-time well first of all before we get
too deep into the Nitty Gritty I want to
wish you a happy October 27th because
today you are not realize it's kind of a
special day you've got then happy
birthday no no no other things but I
like where your head's at okay your
predictive that's what makes a good
gamer okay
not that though I was gonna say the new
Mario comes out today comes out today
they say that right feel like I did a
stroke but it sound I'm good right
you're fine okay Mario the new Mario
comes out today the new stranger things
season 2 comes out today and the iPhone
X all come out today my question which
one are you most excited for I'm gonna
have to go with stranger things
interesting simply because the
soundtrack always played on the stream
that's true that new retro wave you know
right you're bringing me there you know
I I mean we could have gone deeper with
I feel like you should I feel like I'm
sad that you stopped there I yeah we
gotta get Dan can we get a recording of
this and put it in the mixer and we just
we can make do some work with that okay
why aren't you or did you work on the
soundtrack I did until I did it's just
one yeah it's coming soon it's Calvin's
LP yeah are you fan of the show you just
I am a fan of the season one
like season 1 I didn't like the fact
that I had to wait a full entire year
that's the that's what really sucks
about following because I'm a guy I
stream my shows I don't only until
recently did I have cable money right
that's a new thing for me yeah I'm doing
very well right yeah but waiting a whole
year is just uh how do people do it I
don't know and then when you get it a
year later you watch it in one day right
exactly
Wow that's wait another year that's one
of the things that Netflix does that I
hate and love both it's like yeah well
drop house of cards all in one day and
then you have nothing to live for it for
a whole year and thanks for doing that
yeah have you seen any other reviews on
it yet are they oh no I don't know it's
out right I think I can watch it this
evening oh okay I didn't know like no I
think what Dan are in is that available
to watch right now thank some people
have watched already ooh is it out right
now I'm all right you guys thanks for do
some research on reviews let's let us
know if we should be - I hate reviews
though but I I hate reading my views I
don't know anything about anything about
these people there well gosh started you
know the season one started off real hot
the episode wine is great they recast
this listen who are you okay right who
the hell are you
yeah do you have critics I have a lot of
critics yeah do they sound like that as
well and I'm not Susanna Ron tomato by
the way so what is it 94% oh good news
very good but what do you what are your
critics say about you I don't have any
critics everyone just agrees that I'm
the best yeah I mean like everyone just
agrees that I have the best shot in the
game that I'm in the sniper on
battlegrounds the game that I stream on
a daily basis like everyone just
believes and I'm the best looking
streamer on Twitch right really no
critics I don't know I think I'm kind of
perfect okay that's fair yeah that must
be nice well unlike unlike you stranger
things does have some critics apparently
6% of them who didn't like it but um
that first show was great wasn't it
yeah really surprised me Netflix has
come out with some powerful
powerful swings you got like spooky
alien ships and the trailer oh never
heard of it this is great give me a
tough interview the new what's that
movie that everyone loves but I'm
getting a heart I'm getting actually a
lot of criticism for my remarks
regarding it the Blade Runner yeah what
did you think about it I thought I
wasn't impressed tell me the truth
I wasn't impressed because it started
off like this Wow okay I'm into this I'm
diggin it and then it just went flatline
for me consistently all the way through
the movie
I got it we've been kind of keeping this
as a secret I'm afraid to express that's
what we anti I hate it yeah I you know
why I hate it when you see a movie like
that the promises so much yes the
successor to so much you expect great
things
and everybody's sucking its dick about
oh my god it's changed my life
I cried emotional revelation it was
boring
nothing happened dude I was promised
more mm-hmm I agree with you and thank
you for saying that
yeah the Twitter feed blew up and I
heard about it for weeks and weeks and
I'm thinking okay I'm going to the cine
appleís theater where you can grab three
or four gin and tonics and a steak
dinner right and sit in a recliner
leather recliner anywhere you want in
the theater and spend 30 $40 $50 on a
full night right and that's what I did
halfway through the movies right ah yeah
I wasn't impressed visually it was nice
okay yeah visually it was awesome but it
really just and then like it's weird
that people liked it so much because I
feel like in this day and age it's very
I'm I like artistic yes films but this
was artistic in a way that didn't do
anything for me mm-hmm I don't want to
give away the night seriously we have to
keep this a secret until now
this is the first time thanks for giving
me the confidence about that I
appreciate that a lot
means lots of man are you a Nicolas
Winding what's his name Nicolas Winding
ring he's a director of driver
Griffen we had an
Finn I think is Rhett driver yeah the
drive Oh everything yeah drive about
Halle rising
anyways very artistical what do you
think about the guy
awesome he's one of my favorite okay and
he has a very like that movie had a very
similar style to the way he directs but
I feel like it just wasn't pulled off at
that level right of artistical ability
right you know I don't want to give away
the twist of the film yeah yeah but I
didn't like it I thought it was a bunch
of BS and I'd like to explain that in
further detail but I have too much
respect for you guys at home but that
being said get out now listen you are
famous by the way you're not excited for
Mario can I go back to that Tindle I
mean listen I deal with high-level free
a person shooter high-skill open-world
interactive apocalyptic arenas where you
got to be the last guy alive and you
have to kill demolish every one that
gets rails and a hat that he throws that
frogs and becomes a fraud I want to talk
about competitive gaming the highest
level try getting into the body of a
Tyrannosaurus Rex as Mario as he saves
peach from literally being raped by a
giant [ __ ] lizard the stakes couldn't
be higher
okay I'll reconsider
okay Matt you put it that way I might
reconsider yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you
we're getting through there's a lot I
feel like we're having some real there's
a connection yeah except for that
haircut yeah I'm growing it out all
right ponytail or duck tail I was
thinking um what do you call these i
buddycall Hornitos
curly sideburns but they're not
sideburns they're right you said
pigtails would be up here that's what I
want that stuff right yeah that's done
you so you are famously the blockbuster
video game champion of 93 and 94 next
two times two times yeah not one year
and then sec six seven years later
back-to-back back-to-back consecutive so
can you tell us a little bit about those
two years how did you overcome it what
games were you victorious and bring me
back there sure absolutely obviously it
starts at a local local store right so
what kind of store was it just a local
blockbuster store and we're all we're
all good epics begin and just demolished
Sega Genesis all the way through to the
end second year it's when they actually
had location and a finish line my finish
line was marine world in front of the
killer whale exhibit that's where the
finals were played finish line the
finish line meeting at the end of the
tournament meaning that's the grand
stage the championship station yeah yeah
and so you know we played in be a gym
judge dredd Sonic the Hedgehog good old
classics yeah yeah so you had to not
just be a like a pro on one game you had
to be multi-talented this was a
triathlon this was a triathlon
interesting yeah and they had 250 tube
TVs lined up squares squares because
they didn't have I didn't have why back
then Oh No
yeah and a little-known fact anybody
that because the last game that was
played in the championship NBA Jam
anybody if anybody knows that if you if
you play NBA Jam by yourself it doesn't
switch at halftime
meaning the direction that you played a
game so you're always trained to go
right and when you go left all the
controls are actually reversed that's a
little wacky and so in the championships
that was the big sort of dilemma is that
who gets the second you know who gets to
be first player who gets this be second
player mm-hmm and so that's where I
worked my magic so I knew this right I
stayed at first player all the way
through to the finish right yeah yeah
and that was that that was the end
that was the edge and that was the end
trophy in the room I don't talk about it
it's under wraps so it wasn't
necessarily a skill victory is more like
a hold down p1 victory it's it's a skill
victory okay I understand I'm gonna get
the facts straight it's a historical
moment yeah I made JFK just they just
cleared all the documents for that so I
feel
this is something so how did that go is
that a is that probably somebody killed
him I was all in the documents somebody
killed him okay
some guy had a gun he shot him I was
like wow the truth is out there man
actually I don't know I don't know man I
don't trust anyone the internet you've
got like people on art Donald people on
our conspiracy people on like socialism
all like picking little berries yeah
apparently there was two shooters
apparently I don't even know how it's
related but the CIA was like you know
doing some [ __ ] somewhere you kind of
look like you could fit I'm the I'm the
one-time JFK assassin and I say that's a
joke I have no intention of
assassinating any presidents living or
dead sometimes you just gotta clear the
air though I don't know what do you
think happen at JFK I don't know did you
know the moon's made out of metal that's
probably true like technically true
right that's what I've heard I've heard
they record sound waves I told you that
I well I watch a lot of ancient aliens
Yeah right
History Channel exactly is that where it
is yes they're like I watched you don't
even need to say that I watch a lot of
History Channel that sounds credible
yeah it's a hundred percent the moon is
made out of metal okay so can I mean
expand on that uh I had a few gin and
tonics when I was watching this episode
let's see if I could remember I believe
they found out or they they're
theorizing that based on when they'd
lift it off from the moon and they shot
the Rockets off to lift off they
recorded the reverberations or the sound
waves right those rockets landed back
onto the moon hmm and the frequency in
which they received was like something
absolutely crazy sure and like there's
no way that they could you know if it
was a solid rock or whatever the
material is there's no way would it gave
off that frequency and they think it's
something like either it's like solid
metal or hollow in the inside and the
outside is it yeah anyways is it one of
these guys the guy with the hair who's
doing this I see this guy that the guy
that guy yeah way up here so but but
basically the moon is real because iíve
heard consider
see theories people say is the moon real
at all
so you why I'm real you're not taking it
that far does it exist or is it just I
think it exists I just think it's not I
think it's a lamp
till I'm the moon is a lamp have you've
gone that deep I think the moon is
artificial element floating above the
earth and if we can all get down with
that yeah let's make a [ __ ] show
about it yeah
ancient aliens no yeah I feel like
anyone's qualified to appear on that
show by the way just some [ __ ] guy
like listen trust me the pyramids
impossible to build what are your
credentials
I own a car wash anyway listen you know
I'm kind of a videogame champion too I
mean I was [ __ ] I mean a my glory
story after hear yours oh oh I was it
all started at blockbuster okay not that
glorious we don't scoff until you hear
the story Mario Kart 64 Double Dash ooh
not 64 sorry Gamecube okay you ever
played that No most competitive game
ever made double - yeah twice as
competitive really twice the speed in
adrenaline okay we me and my friends
used to play this game non-stop ten
hours every day in college I flit early
failed out of college and had to do a
five-year because of this game
dedication one two first ever tournament
at my college UCSC host mm at our
cafeteria not as glorious as a
blockbuster button people eat they drink
there a lot of stuff goes on hundreds of
people in there people traveling from
all across the state to compete in this
Double Dash tournament this one guy
shows up with the camera crew his
[ __ ] friend is filming him because
he's so confident he thinks he's the
best okay there's four of us four of us
who are prob'ly this is all we care
about the friend who's the worst he's a
little slow I think he had a birth
defect he's the worst of all of us this
guy with the camera comes up against him
first our friend with like Down syndrome
whatever
creams him guy he turns off the camera
he's crying and he leaves because his
our number-four cream disaster
all the like I think there was like 500
people in that tournament the last four
people all four of us in the finals
guess who won I'm thinking maybe you it
was a friend with author with the
Asperger's he were like he was on like a
rayman level actually oh here slow but
he was really good at the game huh I got
second though so you didn't okay but it
was crazy
so I mean nobody could beat that guy
nobody he's like Rain Man he's counting
cards what year was this hmm before or
after 1993 it was after yeah was after
that was that just is that the golden
day I'm the golden air I mean that had
to have been the first LAN tournament
right yeah
so let me what is what is a lot of
people on YouTube who watch this who are
just kind of like hey I'm a guy who
listens to podcasts yeah may not know
what twitches or what a twitch streamer
is mm-hmm
it's very unique like people are
starting to understand like what YouTube
is what youtubers are but twitch is
still more underground I'd say one of
the part of the reasons why I like ins
respectfully do so much as a yeah
elevating it and I I think that you can
reach like for example my brother-in-law
there's a 45 year old high school
teacher is a huge failures
they can't even game and he's learning a
lot yeah that's the amazing part so what
is it what does it mean to you what
makes a good twitch streamer what makes
a good twitch streamer yeah have you
ever had anybody from twitch on your
show by the way if you don't mind me we
had um I not
we had like totalbiscuit but he's not
like he's like a podcast guy I guess the
question I was asking is have you ever
had the face of twitch on your podcast
no no yeah so we have some high level
knowledge to talk about yeah tell me
everything what you need is obviously
you need to be good-looking okay okay
number one if you're not gonna look in
people are gonna be
they don't want to stare at you for six
or eight hours right like that's just
the fact so thank God I'm blessed with
good looks right that's number one
number two you got to be an
extraordinarily high level gamer I mean
out of this world where people are a
jaw-dropping every time they're watching
you do 360 Snipes in a 1v1 situation to
win the game they go god damn I'm so
glad I am subscribed to this guy in his
channel right right so you got to be an
incredible gamer number three I mean
everything else just sort of compiles
right like the you know like I show off
the arena I show I give you a lick you
have to be open right you have to be
open you have to be able to like
understand I could show you the inside
of my bedroom right I give people a
glimpse inside my bedroom you know I'll
dance in front of my king-sized waterbed
after I win a game nice so that's number
one I think I have an arena that looks
really nice I want to do that at night
yeah I recommend a waterbed by the way
yeah it's pretty do they sell those
still I don't know my mind's I've had
mine for eBay 25 plus years okay
surprise that thing's not leaking no
it's saltwater water and it takes Givens
I don't know its scientific right off
sure yeah but what makes you know you
have to just be charismatic I think you
know you have to be able to just
understand there's I think you have to
be able to cater to a wide spectrum of
people you know a lot of people really
get into the niche of a you know I'm I'm
a gamer I'm a first-person shooter
I'm good at it and I can kind of
communicate with my chat and then I'll
say the f-word every couple seconds and
just [ __ ] and sit in front of the
camera and then there's other people
that take it a little bit farther right
like they cater to the wider spectrum of
their demographic you know I've got
people I've got parents sitting in my
sit into my chat and I know that I'm on
their big screen and they got a two
three-year-old right there in front yeah
that's thought I mean there's so I can't
be going like this and f you and you
know I but at the same time I could
still be me the Dominator yeah so I
think that's important so I think you
have to just as a
streamer you have to recognize like five
you know what is what is your thing and
how do you how can you carry that thing
over a large demographic of people like
and you know I don't have the magical
answer but that's uh well you you were
streaming and making videos like I mean
I was I was looking at your channels
back like back back like day one YouTube
you were seven years ago doctor
disrespect existed on YouTube and were
you twitch streaming are you streaming
back then no I was on YouTube
I'd straight up YouTube we would some
sketches sketches and lead into gameplay
right I'd commentate over the gameplay
that was the concept did you ever stream
before like cuz I know you took a hiatus
and then you came back yeah I know I've
never know so we started about a year
and a half ago back to non streaming
okay but the absence between that and
YouTube was what five six years or
something lived likes it like seriously
consistently putting out videos so what
made you think that like most people are
like oh I want to be a youtuber mm-hmm
what made you want to go from YouTube to
twitch ah I think part of it was the
fact that I knew I had to have a lot
more resources in order to do YouTube
stuff you know it's a little bit higher
production at that time I were just
blessed to be around some good friends
that we always had a camera around us
and you know we could just shoot at all
times and I could just cut it up throw
it up on YouTube boom we got something
now it's you know you know everyone's
got a little bit you know there are
different directions in life and you
know I sort of found myself like how can
I do everything myself
and twitch it's pretty easy to do that
consumes you got to do is to set it up
set up your whole set up at home and do
your thing in the nerve just handle it
yourself so what how do you explain cuz
on Twitch you your success has been
almost like meteoric well I like that
was that a word
meteoric yeah you were like a [ __ ]
meteor down to this planet I mean for me
your name just started popping up
everywhere and I started watching you
and I was like man this guy's pretty
cool good what happened like did you
really explode out of nowhere did I just
miss something
I mean you've Pub G right was was a big
turning stone
I think I think h1z1 okay I started with
h1z1 and that was winning that game was
really you know kicking off but you know
those devs what they came now but I was
riding that wave and it I think that the
pace of that game the speed the violence
the momentum you know associated with
that game and being able to talk
proximity chat right you know being able
to talk to a guy in real time as you're
fighting him really showcase you know
the personality or the character
character of the doc right right and so
we just kind of ran with yeah so h1z1 is
where I'd say where it start and then
you know we're lucky enough to have
another battle royale game come come on
and you know it's at it's at the level
of where it's at so we're just sort of
riding a wave right yeah the battle
royale wave the battle royale wave is
pub G just like as far as I can tell
it's like the same game more or less in
it made by the same guy same person
who's yeah the concept the whole concept
of the game yeah it's pub G overrated
what do you think it's pub G overrated
from a design standpoint no I think the
design is fantastic you know you you put
in another map you put in some
additional content with the game the
shelf life is there is no limit to the
shelf life
the problem with a shelf life right now
is the is the ability of the studio to
get it to a level where we're not
dealing with desync and lag issues like
a triple-a game feel like has been
forever
yeah it's been a while like since I
started playing the game months ago the
game in September had sold 10 million
copies well you're looking at 300
million in revenue yeah and that's in
September and [ __ ] and that's beta
right and it's free pre alpha what what
is the terminology yeah it's a launch
the game and let it be finished and just
support it right
I played dota for like years and that
game was in beta for like three years
and then also they're like oh it's non
beta anymore I'm like what is it yeah
what does it mean yeah but what's going
what do they need to do because I feel
like nothing's changing in that game and
I'm frankly getting bored of playing it
with all these issues yeah yeah I mean
it again they just need to opt
my is it they got all the money in the
world is that is I don't not enough I
think they're it's it's basically I
think it comes down to industry talent
engineering talent I mean this is just
me talking like from my experience and
being in the industry
I think they need probably need a little
bit more engineers they're working there
at their resources around because they
are getting close to launching Xbox so
I'm sure they've shifted a lot of the
resources getting ready for that launch
right again I'm not an official
representative the studio size yeah but
this is sort of meek talking out loud so
I think they're they're sort of
prioritizing where the resources need to
be at the moment and I think they're
starting to understand some of the
feedback the community's giving them and
so I think they're they're starting to
shift the resources back on to you know
how do we get this game optimized how do
we get it it sounds like you're
relatively forgiving of the company all
I've seen your rage quite a bit and I am
not forgiving they understand exactly
all right how I feel right oh yeah on a
daily basis well you could to go back as
you said your knowledge on the industry
because there was that five year gap we
were talking about you are actually
working for sledgehammer games right
I built half the maps for that's the
college fair I know I get it I get it
it's incredible how was that like
genuinely genuinely I loved it okay so I
love the creative side of things I loved
it it was a it was a fix for me on a
daily basis to go there and just head
down and just design stuff and get
feedback and work with artists and do
you know design meetings and and play
tests and I get to talk to the creative
directors and leads and you know we
formulate like strategies on map release
like it was just you know to be able to
work on a Call of Duty one of the
biggest triple leg is yes it was it was
it was a in a in a sense it was a
privilege right but me as a person I
just couldn't I got I don't I don't deal
with politics very well I just don't I
guess that's just a weakness
Court might read corporate communication
and politics and stuff like that and
ultimately you know that's that's on me
you know for for that something happen
at work where you were just like I can't
do this anymore was it just it was just
over time you know is one of those
things where it's like okay I kind of
want to do something else yeah I
understand that yeah I had a I actually
had a desk shop for five years same
amount of time I didn't love it
necessarily but it grind it grinds on
you right you felt that even though you
still loved the job yeah mm-hmm I miss
it too
I miss some change my hands dirty and
building stuffing you ever want to make
your own game that's an idea that's been
tossed around a lot yeah
it just depends on how all the pieces
fall into place
you know like budget you know who am i
working with like yeah you know because
you certainly want some very trustworthy
partners that know what they're doing a
lot of industry experience man you want
talent too from the engineering talent
to creative guys to people like I run
the studio correctly and everything I
keep kind of need to know that stuff so
important we're learning from kind of
running our own operation on smaller
scale it's like the people's just it all
comes down to finding good people it's
crazy lutely doesn't matter how much
experience they have or I mean it does
but like just I don't know some people
are just you can do it listen why do you
want to design a game what are you
thinking um call it YouTube
personalities no I don't know we have a
mobile game that we're working on kind
of top-secret stuff but I'll tell you
all about it okay live right now yeah
right now I'll tell you okay I wonder if
they'll get angry who's gonna die it's
taken to who's gonna develop it faster
we've already been working on it it
probably will never be made what's the
cause I'm not gonna talk about it it's
gonna be awful you'll be surprised it's
gonna be awful let's take a brief break
for to thank our sponsors we've got a
lot of goofs left we're gonna take some
calls from fans live whoa yeah we've got
the technology okay well these things on
yeah well pipe those in they're not on
the phone yet okay hold on a second yeah
yeah I know all right where do I park
lane
well why is it being towed okay that's
going deadly yeah no worries so brief
thank you to our sponsors and we will be
back with the doc stay tuned
thank you to jigsaw the positively
spookiest film of the year coming out to
date October 27th for sponsoring this
episode of the tree podcast and helping
us out on h3 to fulfill our dreams of
making the god VAP these guys are
awesome it was a joy and a pleasure
working with them so if you're up for a
good spook this Halloween season head on
to the theaters and enjoy a little bit
of jigsaw god bless ya it's hot it's
spicy see the movie actually need that
excuse me and thank you too hello fresh
hello fresh is a company that makes
cooking great and fun for me it's a
hassle you create pans you got to go
shopping you got to choose oh is this
cilantro fresh who can tell I did go to
culinary school hello fresh decides for
me they sent me the cilantro and the
ingredients and everything it's a joy
they send it all to you and you cook it
it's delicious every time and you're
done that's the joy of hello fresh back
me up you'e backing you up
thank you I wasn't well listen it's
delivered right to your door and
insulated recycled packaged with and
it's refrigerated as well
they got three plans to choose from you
got classic you got veggie you got
family meat fish seasonal produce me and
yellow we have a lot of fun we cook it
at home we say hey it's hella fresh
night it's delivered to your house in a
box with ice come on you don't need to
be there to receive to accept it you
know what I say when I arrives at the
door I go hello fresh listen my friends
go to hello fresh and use the code h3
podcast to get $30 off your first week
of deliveries alright listen you're not
going to spend all night in the kitchen
making recipes for 30 minutes there's
lots of one pot recipes seriously speedy
cooking and minimal cleanup each week
there's even a 20 mm
a meal on the classic menu so do us a
favor feed yourself good for once eat a
nice meal your mom will be happy get $30
off your first weeks of deliveries by
going to hellofresh calm and use the
code h3 pod cast thank you to them and
we've got quip
I love quit they make this snazzy
tubular vibrating toothbrushes it's a
tube and it's very great listen here's
something to chew on
many recent studies suggest that having
good oral health impacts your overall
health that means that if you don't take
good care of your mouth and your mouth
goes to decay and [ __ ] well you can have
a lot of other problems but apparently
that can cause your liver to fail and
also your I've read that people have
just don't die I believe that you skip
brushing you die yeah and the good thing
about quip is that it makes skipping
brushing difficult because it's such a
joy using this product as an electric
toothbrush that packs a premium
vibration and timer features into ultra
slim design and it's half the cost of
bulk gear brushes it's basically like
Apple designed a toothbrush again you
know it's got the same color schemes I
guess what they mean is like slick
simplistic design but to me Apple is
just like marked up three times past its
value that's not the case here it's like
the opposite so it should be the anti
apple of design I don't think most
people think about that when they think
yeah sure Apple I have a problem I have
actual problem with Apple I'm not a fan
but listen you can subscribe to receive
a new brush head on a dentist
recommended three month plan for just
five dollars including free shipping I
shouldn't drink diet coke before doing
this I got burps quip is backed by
leading dentist and was named one of
Time Magazine's best inventions of 2016
and they won 2016 GQ a grooming award
made it
Oprah on her own list her list names
Oprah oh you know what else yeah exactly
an amount it's like but you know what
else the quick can make you do with the
oh oh it can give you an oaf ace quip
starts at just 25 no it's like some
people have described as being orgasmic
in all faiths okay because you enjoy the
brushing so much and not because it
resembles a sex toy in any way but it's
nice that you know multiple applications
is good for for a mouska I would say
right now that's the old face and it
works here great so good like that okay
they know how to price it's just
vibrating to man it's killer right now
go to koat.com slash h3 and get your
first refill pack free with a quip
electric toothbrush that's your first
free refill get quick calm /h 3 and
finally my friends this is an incredible
product stitch fix men they're like a
lot of guys you probably think of a
million things you'd rather be doing
than shopping for clothes loser
get real between the parking and the
crowds at the mall in the endless
browsing and lack of advice online it's
enough to make you want to rock the team
same t-shirt and jeans but you can't so
let me tell you about stitch fix men
they're reimagining how and how to find
and buy clothes and you never even have
to leave your house it's that easy
so imaginary girlfriend it's your
virtual mom they pick up clothes for you
it's it's wonderful they buy it
it's an incredible service I don't think
that it
with sexual favors I don't think that
sex is included or companionship or love
or tender you know tender warm body to
hold at night but they'll dress you and
that's halfway there and that's how you
get the tender warm body so listen up
your personal stylist then gets to work
hand picking new clothes for you based
on your style and budget five items are
delivered right to your door you try
them on at home and you only pay for
what you keep shippings free both ways
so anything you don't want you just send
it back my friends exchanges are always
free - you can get your fix monthly
quarterly or whenever you feel like it
there's no subscription required it's
easy the shipping is free why not give
them a try I promise you'll be hooked
you go to the website you take a quiz
they say hey you like this you like that
and they're like oh my god all of a
sudden you're looking fresh get this
hello fresh you're gonna get a date this
is the beginning of the rest of your
life
get started now at stitch fix calm slash
h3 and you'll get 25% off when you keep
all five items in your box that's stitch
fix dot-com listen up slash h3 to get
started today all right thank you to our
gracious lovely sponsors for help and
support us if you are in the market for
any of those please consider supporting
them to help support the show with that
being said let's get right back into the
disks respect with the doc welcome back
everybody to the h3 podcast live here
with the the doc mr. to time mister
disrespect may I call you that
- time to time / - time to time okay all
right yeah glad we got that cleared up
let's take some calls from the people
the good people out there let's take a
call from chicken Derby chicken Derby
talk to me and tell me what is good my
my dog hey what's poppin dude chicken
was just wondering uh what you think
fortnight like can I compete with pub G
or will the standard
fortnight what kind of game is fortnight
fortnight say a battle royale game but
if if chicken wants to answer that good
okay so it's like a it's a clone can we
call it a cologne let's call it yeah all
right clones thank you for your question
chicken appreciate you papa bless you
the dead thing is not gonna like clone
their clones
okay I'm just taking that thanks man do
you have any stake in fortnight I I
don't you know those guys they're knowns
okay so what say anyway what do you
think about the game I think it's
fantastic I mean that okay it's it's
it's a game obviously number one
optimized hmm and that is why its
popularity is just like stream I kept
trying yeah you'll love it if you like
pub G you'll like fortnight you'll love
it because you're probably terrible at
video games and it's one of those games
you can easily pick up right yeah dan
can you bring in the Gamecube please
double dash on this television double
dash does that mean you have a doodoo no
it means you you can't it means you're
gonna have to double dash to keep up
with me okay the one time all right but
three times previously ninety four five
and six oh okay
I've lead back to anyway so four nights
good four nights great I think I think
this is the shelf life of the game it's
really early so I don't know
I don't know where the direction of
where they're gonna take the game right
now
you got one map it's easy to jump into
everyone's loving it it's an optimized
game they have skins that are coming out
Halloween skins people are loving that
from a competitive standpoint I don't
know how competitive the game is or can
be because there are tiered weapons and
whenever you introduce randomized to
tiered weapons it's it becomes a and
I've talked about it on my stream before
and this is one of the reason why I
don't necessarily play it all the time I
just haven't gotten into it enough yet
but you know I'd hate to play a guy
who's as good as me or as equal as me
yeah and he has the same weapon as me
but guess what he has the gold weapon
and I have the silver weapon so they
have
like how do you get the gold what random
it's random looting yeah
and to me I mean I've said it from day I
mean I've been saying it for years even
working at sledgehammer games you could
and that's one thing that we did at
sledgehammer games was eliminate any
randomization in the game okay yeah the
randomization takes away from the
competitors yeah yeah and but at the
same time I mean you got IC pro players
Call of Duty players playing fortnight
you know Pro Halo players I mean just
hike high-level PC players playing the
hell out of fortnight and I think it's
because again it's optimized it's
fast-paced and it's fun do you think
that pub G is a is a good competitive
game it's it's commits competitive to in
a sense that it has a certain level of
depth to the gameplay with scopes and
leading bullet lead and all that stuff
right but they're still the element like
and I talked about it too and this is up
for debate is they'd still randomized
loot like a fight land at this house I
don't know what's gonna be in the house
right um that is super annoying about
the game it's like sometimes you can
just search a whole village
yeah and you yeah nada I think there
should be
I think if battlegrounds wants to take
it to the level that they want to take
it at even from a commentating
standpoint like commentators the problem
I think with Battle Royale games is that
the game starts off everyone's flying in
right and when they fly in they land as
a commentator what's the story that
you're trying to tell well the only
story that you're really trying to tell
is okay that's TSM and they're on the
south end they're gonna look at looting
the military base we'll see what comes
of that what's you know blow it slow
start it's slow start and there's not
much of a narrative to it right in it
but if you were to if you're to take a
look at the fact that like a let's let's
if there was set loot in this map and
everyone was landing down and you see
two teams going to an area as a
commentator you have knowledge like a
there's where the car the sniper is and
there's a level three helmet there you
can actually spectate that and figure
out which team gets that a quantity and
getting thinner yes and there's a
narrative to talk about sure so I think
it seems like they just need a
completely different
mode of playing to make it an actual
high level crib game yeah yeah they
should pray that seems like within
reason they should at least try it out
yeah they shouldn't see how its received
so when you when I hear you describing
what you think is a high level
competitive game my mind goes to like
csgo are you a fan of that game I'm a
fan of csgo
yeah yeah I'm a fan of csgo I think the
one thing with csgo for me obviously its
1516 year old game I didn't personally
grow up playing the hell out of it I
I've actually recently got into playing
really
yeah burst stream csgo ice cream what
once in a while now are you good at it
and I'm the best sniper in the game
right yeah I played a game just to get
this the OP that's it
right I'll go handgun handgun handgun
handgun I finally I could buy the OP
thank you so you're that guy I'm that
guy I like that guy yeah I'm that guy
too
um I had totalbiscuit
on the previous episode he was talking
about competitive gaming too and he I
think he we agreed between the two of us
that csgo might be the best competitive
game ever made because it's it's been
around for so long it's still so heavily
played and it pretty much fits all the
criteria you described of being like not
random there's a story to tell there are
certain places that you everyone
converges on yeah and I mean we have
even talked about level design that's a
whole that's your expertise right yeah
there's like systems right there systems
there's player mechanics and then
there's like the actual level design
aspect of a lot of games right do you
think that level design is kind of like
unappreciated I think so well I think I
think level design was it seemed like it
was valued a long time ago I mean you
saw great I mean Counter Strike levels
so this day are same same but there's
still like the best right because
they're so well balanced and you look at
old Halo Maps
you know like Halo 2 Maps and you know
and they're caught there's a reason why
those old ones are starting to still be
recreated even with all the new halos
coming out or whatever I just think
there's I think I don't know I don't
know why but it seems like oh the older
maps it seems like everything now is is
catering to the wrong to the wrong
reasons pacing of the game being able to
like right out of spawn you're able to
engage combat a lot quicker so it's
catering to a wider spectrum of people
rather than like the you know trying to
introduce that skill gap so but in like
what game are you are you thinking I'm
in particular that does that in terms of
what like one that like are there new
levels in csgo that you think aren't as
good as the old ones and it's just like
catering to instant conflict oh well you
see I don't have too much experience
with some of the new counter-strike DLC
stuff that's come out I think they're
fun to play but I don't know I think the
pacing and the knowledge of the
old-school Maps is are very unique
mm-hmm it is pretty interesting that
like dust de dust2 all these these maps
been played for so long yeah and it
really is interesting how you as a gamer
it's like if the map is good you don't
realize it's like if the map designer is
good they don't get any price and if it
sucks they get [ __ ] yeah it's kind of
like the gun there's no complaining yeah
have you played cop head if you want to
get in on the most competitive
cutting-edge games I have a limited
supply of monitors and keyboards you'll
break a lot playing that probably all
right let's take another call from the
Great and illustrious Ryan Gardner hello
what I speak to me doing good how are
you bud I'm doing great thanks for
asking so why wouldn't to ask was
whether you fought there any current or
upcoming games that you see more of the
potentials gained a lot of attention
switch or YouTube great question thanks
man appreciate you yes ma'am great
question because I'm trying to find
those games yeah I'm trying to find
those games I had a lot of uh here's the
thing debt like that and I think that's
the dilemma of
of streaming on Twitch and the state of
the the industry itself is destiny to is
the perfect example
fantastic triple a game beautifully
designed from the you know the PvE to
the PvP aspects of the game like it
feels good it's felt like it just
there's a lot of depth destiny to I mean
it's amazing
actually I'm I play to yet but I want to
try it PC okay do PC yeah the problem is
is a watchable is it a spectating thing
and from what I've seen on twitch thus
far since its launched a couple days ago
I I I'm not seeing people aren't
watching it they aren't watching the
enthusiasm is in there as a spectator
and it's it's very interesting like what
is that next game that is well that as a
gamer I want to play and the streamers
the you know that the people that it's
good for everyone it's gonna be good for
everyone so what is it about pub
Cheetham it is so exhilarating to wash
because I almost don't even understand
the success of the game I don't think
it's there is exhilarating the
exhilaration of watching I think it's
more of the narrative that's behind it a
I give to watch this guy from point A he
drops in with nothing and it's a 35 40
minute game if this guy he gets into the
last one v1 situation to win it that's
fun and you watch this story and it's a
lot of these like every every time you
land it's gonna be a brand new story
right yeah that's really what I like is
that I don't need to be a gamer to
understand what you're doing in the game
right like I see it's very clear to me
if you're doing good or not for example
when you play something like Starcraft I
have no idea or even yeah overwatch I
don't really know how are you doing if
I'm watching and there's one simple like
piece of data that's all that's as a
spectator if you don't even play the
game that's all you need to know is that
how many people are left it's that
number in the top right and it just goes
down it goes down it goes down you got
to make a game do it I think you got the
X Factor you know what's going there I'm
standing by okay I'll give me money okay
yeah like okay like I'll give you like
500 bucks title the game Lambos and
steroids okay yeah okay I'm out I have
$500 check right
damn right this minute checked well
that's all you need right that's all
games gone yeah good
that'll get in the door you know what
I've noticed too about pub G because you
were saying like the games that people
are making now are designed for like
instant conflict and instant action
mm-hmm but pub G I think what's great
about it as a spectator sport and even
as those streamers at there is a lot of
downtime so you have time to like
interact with the audience
that's a yes still play it's a great
point absolutely yeah you can looting
like the beginning of the game if you're
not if you're not the type of gamer that
lands in a hot spot you know you land
somewhere else it's like okay I can
casually loot we can interact the
convenient donation subs whatever and
you know you feel like you're part of
your community in the community feels
like you're they're part of the game and
what's going on with the broadcasting
was really just like a perfect storm I
feel like and just exploded yeah big
time 300 million shekels actually much
more than that was ain't worth what
dollars are trust me folks
me and Ella have streamed before on
Twitch and it is brutally exhausting we
found like will stream for like three or
four hours do you get up and stretch
no I order pizza yeah three sons cuz I
take my guys I take everyone to the
again to you know to the locker room
this is like Daddy club locker room oh
go through nice little stretch routine
people like there's a static stretch
dynamic stretching oh that's okay yeah
so that's what helps you get yeah
absolutely
yeah and again I talk about it all the
time it's I mean steroids is illegal
steroids from one of the hots what oh
yeah I heard they have good steroids oh
yeah and Elise go that's where my
parents live yeah yeah they can great
great place we'll talk about it out
first
yeah they used to live in Jalisco and
they moved back to the States after
someone someone's had a grenade fight
and their neighborhood oh those guys got
some really great steroids by the sound
of it is killer out there but I feel
like it's exhausting also mentally not
really something that like sometimes I
flag after with dream and like there's
like still noise in my head like when
you come back from a club cuz it's just
so intense like well did chat in the
comments
headphones yeah high intensity stuff
music playing the whole time screaming
and yelling and you're on I mean you're
on the whole time and when you when
you're off it's like it's a deep breath
it's wow it's fun though it's fun
how do you do it every day I see rise
steroids
spin your spin class and steroids that
should be the title of your
autobiography what do you think about an
IRL stream in a spin class I think your
fans would love to watch ok do you know
what they're doing I'm won't be there
your fans will love it don't you want me
to join you in the spin class ok do we
wear this where what like do we both
wear this where this is what I wear
every day so it's up to you if you want
to wear that yes 100% cool yeah you need
that there yeah there's not a lot of
shady characters
it's like Jazzercise me meets bicycling
alright how do you I'm curious like you
play you pumped geez you're making you
play it a lot a lot do you still have
fun playing it or is there a certain
blend of you do it for the sake of your
job because you know most your fans
probably want to watch you play punky
right
yeah so is there a point where you just
hate the game so much but you keep
playing it just because you know that's
what your fans want to watch ah I play
the hell out of it because it's the only
thing that's out there it's just it's
just the game I'll try to go back to
h1z1 about h1z1 I get stream sniped
it's it's not it's just not even playing
I mean it's just H wasn't even the speed
of the game I love the momentum
everything but right when you land I
mean it's like if I don't land in your
cop car I'm gonna be swamped in ten
seconds and why is it so much worse on
that yeah damn cuz it's just the speed
of the game you smaller map higher speed
um it's it's more of like all you need
is a AR and you can go
you know you landed battlegrounds you
don't like the house you go into you
might find a newsie if not you just find
a little the armor let's go to the next
house so many layers the depth of the
game is you know it's a lot deeper each
one I'll use a helmet Oh slam yeah the
golden slam getting the cop car go home
is fun to watch I don't know anything
about that game and again talking about
spectators
I watched you play that game it's it's a
thrill it is you're zooming around you
got a shotgun you're talking [ __ ] ah
spicy yes the proximity chat I miss it
because I like to remind these a little
chubby cheeked wannabe unathletic
pigeon-toed sprintin gamers right what
the two times all about yeah for sure
yeah but you don't have brought your
proximity and plugged you - yeah it's
not the same no no one talks everyone's
scared everyone's hiding like a little
kid a little shotgun right where's your
guts right trying to get pissed off now
no I'm getting angry too scary that's
how we play we hide I hide okay the ones
all here so I'll Creek I will stay in a
corner in the 30 minutes my my streams
are called wheat day you're that guy
yeah I'm a killer you're the guy that
uses a pistol for five rounds so you can
buy an OP I've lost so many games on
csgo because you gotta save up yeah it's
just a good life lesson honestly mm-hmm
save up it seems that you've been what's
the this has got to be one of the
longest performance art pieces ever
you're you've been this character the
doc and you're gonna play like you don't
know what I'm talking about okay but do
you have a difficulty transitioning
between yourself and the doctors you're
in character for so long if we're so
intense amount of time is do you have
trouble being like okay now I'm just the
guy literally guy no no we shut it down
we approach it as a business hmm
because essentially on the proverbial
like Fight Club we exactly okay yeah
that's a goal and we approach it as a
business and you know we get in there
get the job done when we're done take
the headphones off
hop put on the robe some gin and tonic
and watch the Golden State Warriors do
their thing
yeah plugin for the worst that's by the
way let's go warriors that go worries
what is the effect of pretending to be I
don't wanna say pretending but like you
spend so much time being someone else
does the line ever get blurred between
no one and the other no no it doesn't ya
ever sit in a restaurant and the waiter
waiter is like annoying and then you you
almost answer in character like come on
ah no no driving is probably one of my
biggest things that outside of playing
battlegrounds that pisses me off so
sometimes when I'm driving this room
this Drive must have been awful for you
this wasn't too bad okay yeah good but
sometimes I could transform me that's
where we followed them home right okay
that's that's a little [ __ ] yeah it's a
little terrifying yeah we follow them
home yeah and trust me the only else is
in the car with but no I could shut it
down and I could turn it on I I get the
sense that the the Edward Norton
character of your life mm-hmm is a very
different than the Brad Pitt character
of your life is that true
absolutely yeah boom Bing right on the
button do you think that like the doc
character that you develop makes you the
Edward Norton part of you more confident
much as as it did in Fight Club ah no
I'm actually pretty I'm actually I'm
actually pretty shy really yeah I'm
actually pretty shy state of myself I'm
pretty shy I don't like that's
incredible I don't like the I don't like
the limelight I don't like being in
front of cameras I'm like taking
pictures it's the exact opposite so in a
way does the it's at least how do I call
it and character kind of helps yeah it's
like I feel the same way too if I put on
a hat or sunglasses then it's like I'm
not exactly myself there's a filter
mm-hmm
do you feel like that that I don't know
how to call it the the Brad Pitt that's
so stupid the doc I feel like if I say
that you won't acknowledge it well if
you feel like the doc has like give it
as like enables you to exist in a
different reality than like something
that you've always wanted to be but you
you couldn't do it as yourself like how
do you because you don't like doing that
but as the doc you're great yeah uh it
certainly is a fix for being able to be
as expressed as a expressive as I want
to be it's funny cuz when I grew up I
was sort of the class clown I was like
the the guy who made people laugh and
stuff like that and then you know as I
got older I kind of got I kind of
transformed into a shy person and you
know I staged myself but I I don't
really socialize too much and if I do
it's like I have to get warmed up to you
a little bit so this allows like this
actually kind of brings back like my old
the old days a little bit and like it
allows me to tap into that being a kid
again and just being aggressive and just
carefree who cares what you think about
me I don't care I'm gonna do anything
and everything that I want to do and
there's nothing you could do about it
yeah kind of kind of expression
expressive like I think that's what
everyone loves about the character too
you know we all long for that yeah yeah
yeah but it feels good it's fun
therapeutic it's very therapeutic
super therapeutic yeah man I wish I
loved it but it reminds me this thing
like we have this vapenation character I
have this theory it's called that guy
it's called the bat guy theory when I
put on when I go out in like New York
and do vague nation it's humiliating I
put on all this ridiculous stuff but
when I put that on I just become I'm
that
I like when you're on the street and you
look like a [ __ ] clown people look at
you and you say oh that's just that who
that guy is
mmm it's not like I'm embarrassed for
that guy who's out there making a clown
himself he's just that guy when you put
on that wig and those glasses you just
become that guy yeah does that make
sense yeah I get it but we've talked
about that but you also don't do this in
public so much I know
no just the events you know and there's
only less than a handful events a year
it's fun yeah it seems seems like it
here's a question from one of the fans
on the subreddit they said you seem like
a very nice and genuine guy in real life
so I'm just curious if you've ever
struggled with the difference between
the two characters I've also to wonder
if you really if you ever have off days
where you just don't feel like streaming
or you're not funny or creative because
it always seems like you're on I
certainly have a lot of off days and
again I blame battlegrounds you know
sometimes you're in the groove you got a
lot of energy and you know the things
sort of just compound and and like I'm
not doing great we're not doing great a
you know for whatever reason like people
in the chat are kind of saying the same
stuff and I'm like you know what's like
something hurry hurry take me to
something I haven't experienced yet you
know in my stream and sometimes you get
into this Lake rhythm or this groove
where it's you can't break out of it
it's like how do I wake up here I need
to wake up like what's someone make me
laugh someone give me like fired up and
sometimes it just doesn't happen so you
like you just kind of get this monotone
of like energy and Cystic I'm kind of
getting close to wrapping this up you
guys right is it the expectation of the
audience were there like they always
want you to be animated and entertaining
I think it's a combination of that and
like I know where I should be and where
I could be and I'm not there and it's
like how do I get there can I get there
I don't know it's like for me one thing
I'm battling now is is like my setup and
in the content that I put out now it's
like I feel like I need a full revamp of
not just I'm not talking graphical
revamp I mean that anybody could do that
like that's not a big deal but just the
approach to streaming in general and the
character or the doc I don't know what
the answer is but I am kind of like
starting to like write out like a plan
of like you know what's the next level
of streaming like version version too
you know sorry I think that's smart I
mean I feel like that drive is is it's
like required of people who like push
forward and are successful I think it's
fun though yeah it's frustrating for me
when I get that feeling but you just you
have to it's much healthier if it's fun
yeah obviously but you have to always be
pushing yourself to changing it better I
think so yeah yeah step outside of the
box yeah mm-hmm
what's next for the doc do you ever ever
and like do you ever want to do acting
or like what's next what's your
aspiration what's your highest goal I
don't know Steve well a lot of it you
know like twitches obviously it's been a
fantastic platform it's continuously
growing it's continuing to grow and the
numbers are just absolutely insane the
amount of new users that are signing up
to the platform you know so we're riding
the wave of twitch and the excitement
around twitch and so I'm you know I'm
pretty excited to see what twitch is
doing here in the future yeah see how
they grow you know I think for the
doctor you know I feel not necessarily
that you know I want to understand
what's the next level of exposure what
is that you know and it was you know
what's twitch again that comes down to
like what's twitch doing and you know
it's a it's an unchartered path kind of
it is yeah like how do you bust out of
twitch to the next level of exposure I
don't know I've never been done yeah as
far as I am aware yeah I think there's
the you know mm-hmm I think given the
character of the doctor one thing that
people if they tune in and they tune in
on like a regular basis is
based off the video gaming dominating
machine and that's all I'm about like I
can actually kind of like I can read I
can kind of relate to people that are in
the sports because I played sports and
you know college sports and I can relate
to people with music and movies because
you know that's that's all been part of
the doctors production and so I can hit
like a wide spectrum of an audience and
so I always thought like it would be
cool if the doctor had like a like a
show like a almost like a one hour you
know like not like Jimmy Kimmel show but
like you know where it's it is you get
guests on doctors the host but we're not
just gonna be talking video games
old-timer but that will be sort of like
the the culture my show right I'm
certain extent but we can talk other
stuff as well I could see that yeah
catches man on the street stuff yeah the
whole variety show totally I love that
yeah I'm in boom $500 check right now
perfect so we got the game I got that I
got a you're certainly I'll give you a
thousand bucks you're set I get fifty
percent yeah yeah working on come from
how do you develop it how'd you come up
with this character the doctor came from
actually originated from halo 2 and it
was a voice and it wasn't a character it
wasn't a visual thing it was all voice
and because halo 2 ism was proximity
chat you know so you could tell the guy
you know you're going to the base with
the team you look at this guy I know
he's upstairs I'm gonna pull the flag
there's nothing he could do about it I'm
gonna demolish him and guess what he's
gonna respond across the map and you got
the other guy on the team listening to
this lunatic coming into the base going
oh [ __ ] you know so it kind of started
like that and actually you know whether
you're on the other team or the team
that I was playing on like people in the
lobby kind of enjoyed that so you can
kind of sense like eight people you're
onto something here a lot of something
yeah yeah and so that just sort of like
naturally developed into like we're
hanging out my buddy's house and they
said hey we should we should make you
know this guy a character like because
we're always into film and stuff like
stupid stuff and so that day I went to
the store and you know picked out the
black steel hey hey the world
oh that's me backstage this is the 2nd
wig or you know let's say implant can we
say that yeah let's talk about it this
is the second version to version 2 yeah
that's impressive that it's lots to do
that long how long's that implant been
around 7 years and I haven't watched it
one time I believe it man
you got to keep it juicy but uh you know
we just went to the store I went to the
store grabbed it and that night I got
the the scopes the the black steel and
then you know we filmed something and I
had a little bit of gameplay and on my
youtube channel it's called Doc's first
video and that was that was like the
first one and it just kind of that's
slowly you know it's incredible you've
kept it up for so long I mean that it's
been like seven years man that's crazy
yeah it really has come to fruition and
developed over the time well I think
yeah yeah and I think I've been I've had
the opportunity to run into a lot of
great people that have helped the doctor
grow and you know that journey you know
it's like one of the first ones was like
optic you know they were big for YouTube
back in the day for trick shots and
before they became like sort of this
real-deal eSports organization but hex
and those guys they were real supportive
of the doctor so we gotta get shout out
to them but mmm yeah it's the journey to
get here has been fun and that's I think
that's important I think it's inspiring
that you've kept with it for so long and
then ultimately achieve success in it
yeah awesome yeah well going from
because I had never livestream right
after did you know after sledgehammer so
I didn't before that was all high level
production videos where it's like okay
we recorded did videos okay let me sit
in Sony Vegas and it cut this up and
added and put me like it's a production
right like and and there was a so you
can hit a certain tone or mood with the
character and it was always like like he
was much darker back then like serious
dark drawn out scenes long stairs I'm
gradually looking at you from a distance
you know like now and so that was a
little scary when I started streaming
like how the hell am I gonna are they
gonna be entertained
it seems like the magic because you're
saying in the beginning they loved your
trash-talking seems like the magic is in
the improvisational just put it out
there capture it yeah get in there
yeah I think so and the energy too and I
think that was important for me to
understand that early on was that just
the this serious doc was not gonna cut
it on twitch because I can get real
boring real fast real person who people
can connect with exactly yeah yes yeah
yeah so what's your favorite activity to
do when you're not streaming in your
free time uh hanging out with the family
obviously you have a wife and a
beautiful life beautiful kid well
daughter little the the dock at the mini
dock the dogs entering this respect
nurse disrespect yeah so it's pretty
much my whole life surrounded by them
they're like that's that's all of them
off stream and we enjoy you know beach
body surfing always talk about our on
saying body surfing it's not a joke
yeah you do by surfing a lot yeah yeah
spin class like we work out together and
everything and that's pretty much my
life yeah that's awesome no use stream
on on a boat oh yeah yeah by the way
just to set this image for those who
don't know about the dock just goes live
one day and he's on a boat playing pub
gee and that's it
he's just on a boat and how did you get
an internet connection out there by the
way from the Asus Zephyrus laptop that I
was using it was a Asus was polite
enough to hook up hook up that whole
situation it was a sponsor it was a
sponsor deal yeah and they proved they
got they made a point yeah uh I'll tell
you right now it wasn't easy to play on
the open sea going 60 70 miles an hour's
fun I mean it's fun but it's not for
gaming yeah this is a this is some fan
service this was
hiya and the suggested question so I'm
just gonna ask you it I'm not really
familiar with these guys but I get a
sense this is a funny question shroud
summit and yourself yeah marry one kill
one [ __ ] one I'm getting that I got I
get that donation a lot okay so you're
ready yeah you can just pass to I could
probably kill it ever although I killed
I kill them they're all no married I
just they kill them both thanks guys for
posting this day last question time I
trust you [ __ ] all right here this is
customary here I have a killed shroud I
should probably say that even if I'd
killed some it so many times it's it's
level but shroud he's my next he's next
on my list okay yep all right watch out
trout yeah this is customary on the show
we usually wrapped it up cuz it's a
little funky a little weird a little
unexpected okay well in sight yeah do
you have any ghost stories any
paranormal yeah or he's UFO alien
sightings tell me about all the weird
[ __ ] you've seen that nobody would
believe yes absolutely
except that one guy on alien technology
yeah what'd he say of everything yeah he
would uh during my last year of college
mm-hmm I was staying up in a house up in
the mountains a friend a friend of Papa
disrespects and they owned a big ranch
big huge acres nice big home and they
had three or four homes on this piece of
property and had like a little small
lake on it I'm he's up like up in the
middle of nowhere and I've heard the
place wasn't you know whatever but he
was he was polite enough to let me stay
there my final year it was about a
30-minute commute to college too from
where they were at and he had to leave
one weekend he said hey can you watch
the house for the weekend I was like
okay cool so I'm sitting there is I
think it was Friday or Saturday now I
get back from school I think it was the
next day Saturday night I'm sitting
there it's about 1:30 2:00 in the
morning I'm laying in bed all son the
phone rings and it's a big house so when
it rings it's like echoes reverbs right
Heaney I'm like what no one calls right
so I go up there I answer
no one's on the phone it's just mean
okay what the hell is this you know I go
back to my bed he had automatic lights
for the driveway I go back to the bed in
the window that the bed we're staying at
this room this window is where you can
see the driveway right when I lay down
ooh
light goes on right let me just go to
the bedroom door and close it I closed
it no joke after I closed it I'm walking
to the bed I hear like I'm running down
the hall and I'm like okay this is nuts
I'm going to bed what was this this was
I got chills this was when this was in
2005 okay so it's it's quite a bit low
go yeah you're a bit of a younger dog
back then the final piece of the puzzle
I went to bed I just had like shut it
down right like just don't even worry
about it give me a bed put the pillow
over the head I can this is this is call
it a night right let's just forget about
this right I wake up in the morning I
walk down the hall he's got this big
huge kitchen beautiful big kitchen all
the cabinet doors are open yeah yeah and
that was my experience at that place I
told Mike I didn't experience anything
else after that like anything that was
weird or hear stuff but I had the place
to myself the whole time that weekend
and that happened during that weekend
and and and so did you tell whose house
was it this is a dad yeah
did you tell him about it yes did he
ever have anything like that happen in
that house no just you
that's so creepy yeah that should screw
yeah I'm always interested to hear what
I've never had a paranormal experience I
wish I did I feel like I'd be more
interesting person yeah thank you no not
not nothing what I got nothing dude okay
but I love hearing other people's
stories so thanks for sharing that
absolutely and finally do you ever plan
on going for
three time and what well it's got to be
three time well it's got to be three
consecutive years oh yeah yeah and I
could have I could have but they're
gonna play Bugsy or Bugsy or whatever
the hell the game is and I don't want to
play Yeah right three times in a row
who's got time for that [ __ ] this time
sounds better
the three times the three time yeah back
to back to back see this is you you
would almost just lie and say two time
at that point as it sounds much better
yes exactly two time right I mean three
it's to the V you know I totally get it
there's well said dude yeah well thank
you to the tube time to the doc for
coming in thank you for braving that
traffic coming and spending this time
with us and sharing your experience god
bless you Oh hopefully your fate doesn't
end the same as Edward Norton from Fight
Club yeah but I appreciate you
nonetheless we're just getting started
yes the revolution is beginning yeah
yeah anyway I wish all the best I love
what you do and really appreciate you
coming here hey thank you for having me
please guys thanks for watching
next Thursday yeah Jory Pearson leave
your questions on the subreddit that is
it for this week guys
appreciate you